One of the standard problems that people study in statistics has to do with purchasing decisions.
Suppose you wish to buy a house.
There are small houses and big houses, but you really like this one special house
build by a famous designer.
This house has a certain price.
Say in US dollars it's $92,000.00.
The question you'd like to ask yourself--is this okay?
Is it too much--you should pay less--or too little?
Let's go an find out.
In statistics, the way we find out is by looking at data.
Let's assume there is a database of previous house sales
of homes in the same neighborhood.
Just for simplicity, let's assume we know about two things--
the size of the home and the cost at which it was sold.
There is a house with 1400 square feet that sold at $112,000,
a much larger one with 2400 square feet sold for $192,000,
and so on for an entire number of other houses.
Now it's a statistics problem.
You have past data, and here is your very first quiz.
Say the house you wish to purchase has 1300 square feet in size.
How much money should you expect to pay?